wir wollten das hier wissen in der BILD
live Redaktion wie steht es eigentlich
um unseren
corona-schutzmonatelang nach der
Zweitimpfung wir haben das testen lassen
gestern in einem großen
bild-testszentrum bei uns im Haus haben
vorgehabt 50 unserer Bildreporter dort
auf Antikörper testen zu lassen das
Ergebnis wir haben 150 unserer
bildreporterkollegen testen lassen
freiwillig in unserem großen Bild
Testzentrum und Patricia Platin hat
jetzt das Ergebnis also wie geht sind
unsere
bild-reporterkollegen noch gegen Corona
geschützt wie viel Antikörper haben die
noch im Blut
vielen Dank Kai und das sehen wir hier
an dieser zunächst mal ein bisschen
schwer zu überblickenden Karte also
jedes kleine Kreuzchen ist ein Bild
Mitarbeiter und das ist das Ergebnis des
Antikörpertest ich habe mir aber
Unterstützung geholt um auch Licht hier
in diese komplizierte Karte zu bringen
Martha weiß ist unserer Leben und
wissenredaktion ist bei uns das den
großen Antikörpertest gestern begleitet
genau und natürlich haben wir auch
medizinische Unterstützung Professor
Kasten Watzl ist uns auch jetzt
zugeschaltet hilft uns ein bisschen bei
der Einordnung denn Professor Wasser es
ist ja nicht ganz klar ab wann an
welchem Wert man sich ganz genau
Boostern sollte oder nicht da gibt es so
ein paar Grauzonen da gibt es so eine
Art wie so eine Art Ampelsystem erklären
Sie uns aber bitte gerne mal zunächst
was genau ist ein Antikörpertest was
sagt der überhaupt aus
also die Antikörper sind wichtig um uns
zum einen vor der Infektion zu schützen
und dann auch schwere Verläufe zu
verhindern deshalb eine Abwehrwaffe des
Immunsystems Gegensatz Virus und diese
Antikörper werden halt durch die Impfung
erzeugt und die kann ich messen und
kriege dann einen Wert der sich
mittlerweile halt in Bau pro Milliliter
ausdrückt und damit wird er dann auch
vergleichbar zwischen verschiedenen
Tests und man kann sicherlich sagen je
mehr Antikörper ich habe desto besser
bin ich auch geschützt das Problem was
wir aktuell haben ist dass wir noch
keinen wirklichen Grenzwert kennen ab
welchem Wert man wirklich welchen Schutz
hat von daher kann man nur sagen wenn
man ganz ganz wenig hat ist es
wahrscheinlich eine Aussage und wenn man
ganz ganz viel hat ist es auch eine
Aussage es gibt halt wie sie schon
gesagt haben in relativ großen
Graubereich noch in der Zwischenzone und
da müssen wir in der Wissenschaft
natürlich noch ein bisschen mehr
forschen
dann schauen wir uns jetzt mal dieses
Diagramm hat er gemeinsam genauer an
jeder Bilder Mitarbeiter ist ein
Kreuzchen jeder der dort unten gestern
in der Schlange stand den Antikörpertest
man muss dazu sagen das ist ein kleiner
Pieks in den Finger Professor weißt du
korrigieren Sie mich wenn ich da
irgendwas falsch erklärt dann wird das
Blut abgenommen es dauert ca 15 Minuten
und dann hat man das Ergebnis dann hat
man diese Zahl warte was genau können
wir jetzt hier sehen hier oben sehen wir
grün grün heißt immer alles ist tipitopy
und rot weiß man immer oh Gott das kann
schwierig werden ja so ähnlich also man
weiß ja dass über 1000 sagt man dass der
Schutz noch relativ gut ist obwohl ja
Herr Professor schon gesagt hat dass das
alles ein bisschen vage ist es gibt
einen großen Graubereich aber alles
unter 21 da kann man davon ausgehen dass
der Schutz vielleicht nicht mehr so hoch
ist und die Verteilung ist halt wirklich
wenn sie das ja ganz ganz wild da ist ja
alles dabei also von ganz unten jemand
unter 20 war jetzt niemand aber hier in
diesem Bereich waren schon auch ein paar
Leute gerade so knapp über 20 das war
zum Beispiel eine Person die gerade die
erste Impfung hinter sich hatte und hat
mir halt gesehen da ist
noch kaum vorhanden oder baut sich
gerade erst auf und dann hier oben da
waren die Leute schon echt begeistert
dann bei den 3000er Werten wer erreicht
denn also jetzt ohne die Namen der
ganzen Kollegen wenn es wollen aber wie
kommt man da wollen wir ja hin das sind
ja quasi die Superhelden die können in
den Winter gehen und können schon fast
von sich behaupten Corona kann mir
nichts anhaben ja es sei denn Herr
Professor sagt jetzt irgendwie das
Gegenteil aber im Prinzip ist es schon
so dass man also es ist natürlich jetzt
nicht repräsentativ was wir gemacht
haben 150 Leute das ist jetzt keine
keine
valide Studie aber man hat schon gesehen
dass die Leute die hier bei den oberen
werten waren ähm das war zum größten
Teil des Menschen ja nur vier aber es
waren Personen die geimpft und genesen
waren und auch eine Person die einfach
doppelt geimpft war es könnte natürlich
sein dass ein Infektion überstanden
wurde ohne dass man es gemerkt hat das
kann man jetzt leider nicht sagen bei
diesem Test konnte man leider nicht
sehen gab es eine Infektion oder ist das
nur die Impfung der hat einfach nur den
Wert ausgespuckt diese Maschine und ja
anhand dessen hat sich halt diese wilde
wilde Konstellation ergeben Professor
watzel wann erreicht man denn überhaupt
hier diese 3000 also diesen Wert wo man
sagt meine Güte mir kann in diesem
Winter nicht viel passieren Muster eine
corona-infektion fast schon zwangsweise
vorausgegangen sein aber kommt man in
diesem Bereich auch schon doppelt
geimpft oder vielleicht gar nur mit
Booster also die Höhe der Antikörper
hängt zum einen natürlich immer von der
Person ab wie gut ich reagiere zum
anderen natürlich auch immer von dem
Impfstoff und ganz wichtig wie lange die
Impfung schon her ist das heißt kurze
Zeit nach der zweiten Impfung hat man
auch schon Leute gehabt die
wahrscheinlich so hohe Antikörperspiegel
hatten die gehen halt über die Zeit
wieder verloren und die Person die jetzt
bei Ihnen auf auf dieser Grafik ganz
oben liegen das waren halt überwiegend
Leute die sowohl die Infektion
durchgemacht haben als auch schon
zweimal dann geimpft waren das heißt sie
sind mehr oder weniger schon gepustert
das was wir jetzt gerade machen wollen
bei den Leuten die erst zweimal geimpft
sind und das schon halbes Jahr her ist
wenn man dann halt noch mal ein drittes
Mal impft dann kommt man auch wieder da
oben in diese ganz hohen Bereiche wir
sehen ja die meisten der Mitarbeiter die
sich gestern haben testen lassen die
bewegen sich so in diesem Feld das ist
so um die tausendermarke ein bisschen
drüber manche bewegen sich bei 2000 was
sind das für Kollegen auch hier nehmen
wir keine Namen aber welche Geschichte
haben die ungefähr ich nehme mal an das
ist so ein bisschen wie bei mir also man
wurde irgendwann im Sommer geimpft hat
zwei Impfungen bekommen und jetzt
irgendwann im Winter würde dann der
Booster anstehen ja also es ist ganz
ganz unterschiedlich es kann man gar
nicht so pauschal sagen also die meisten
aus dem Team wurden tatsächlich im
Sommer geimpft wann hatten ihre letzte
Impfungen vielleicht im Juni Juli und da
sind aber ganz unterschiedliche Fälle
dabei auch Leute die mit Astra sene K
geimpft wurden Infektionen hinter sich
hatten Personen die also das kann man
gar nicht so pauschal sagen
da ist eigentlich alles mögliche dabei
also eher im unteren Bereich aber das
hatte glaube ich Herr Professor Watzl
gestern schon gesagt und das hat sich
irgendwie so ein bisschen bestätigt dass
die Personen die diese einmalimpfung
hatten mit Johnson & Johnson sich
tatsächlich eher so im unteren Bereich
befinden das hatten sie auch so
angekündigt dass die Erfahrungswerte das
so sagen und das hat sich schon so ein
bisschen bestätigt könnte man sagen ja
lassen Sie uns mal Professor Wessel über
diesen unteren Bereich besonders
sprechen denn das sind ja die Menschen
die sich jetzt im Prinzip relativ
schnell um eine booster-impfung kümmern
müssen richtig das ist richtig also wenn
ganz wenige Antikörper vorliegen kann
man sagen dass der Schutz vor der reinen
Infektion wahrscheinlich sehr schwach
ist wie hoch dann der Schutz vor einem
schweren Verlauf ist es ist im Moment
noch sehr fraglich das heißt das da kann
man keine seriöse Aussage zu machen aber
es gibt dann ganz klar die Empfehlung
solche Leute sollten sich um einen
boostertermin bemühen und man muss auch
noch mal ganz klar sagen es ist nicht
gefährlich wenn man sich trotz hoher
Antikörper noch eine boosterimpfung
abholt also da gibt es keine negativen
Effekte es kann halt nur sein dass wenn
man 3000 baupromille Liter Antikörper
hat und sich dann noch mal boostet dass
die boosterimpfung mehr oder weniger
umsonst war aber sie ist zumindest nicht
gefährlich und von daher muss man jetzt
nicht zwangsläufig immer vorher so ein
Antikörpertest machen und wir sehen ja
auch bei diesem Test wenn man zweimal
geimpft ist und die zweite Impfung
wirklich schon ein halbes Jahr oder
länger her ist dann sind die meisten
Leute in diesem mittleren oder teilweise
auch unteren Bereich und um noch mal auf
die Johnson Johnson geimpften gekommen
zu kommen die sind halt meistens nur
einmal geimpft und da sieht man schon
dass da die Antikörperspiegel über die
Zeit deutlich nachlassen und deshalb
hier auch eine ganz klare Impfempfehlung
ist ja auch schon von der STIKO
entsprechend empfohlen worden diese
Leute sollten sich auch um eine zweite
Impfung bemühen und dann muss man nicht
erst ein halbes Jahr warten das kann man
auch schon bis zu vier Wochen nach
dieser ersten Johnson johnson-impfung
machen wie ist denn ihre Empfehlung
abschließend für all die Menschen die
hier im Mittelfeld liegen also die
eigentlich wenn sie es jetzt noch gar
nicht haben testen lassen wahrscheinlich
anzunehmen irgendwo im Mittelfeld mit
ihren Antikörpern liegen sollte sich
jeder langsam jetzt schon auch wenn man
zwei Impfungen erhalten haben um ein
boostertermin kümmern oder zumindest zu
einem Antikörpertest gehen also man kann
da ein bisschen priorisieren und das
zuerst betrifft das sicherlich die
älteren also alle die über 60 sind wenn
deren zweite Impfung schon mehr als
sechs Monate her ist macht es absolut
Sinn sich um eine boosterimpfung zu
bemühen und dann muss man nicht vorher
die Antikörper bestimmen weil wir wissen
dass bei diesen Leuten die
Antikörperspiegel bei den allermeisten
schon in einem Bereich sind wo sie
deutlich von einem Booster profitieren
würden das heißt da ganz klare
Empfehlung sich um einen boostertermin
zu bemühen bei den Jüngeren also unter
60 wenn keine Vorerkrankungen vorliegen
und der die zweite Impfung jetzt noch
keine sechs Monate her ist hat man
sicherlich auch noch Zeit wir sehen
natürlich aktuell dass die
inzidenzzahlen nach oben gehen und eine
boosterimpfung für alle davon profitiert
dann natürlich eine 30-jährige die sich
als Boostern lassen würde weil ihre
Impfung zwei Modell sechs Monate her ist
die hat dann natürlich einen besseren
Selbstschutz aber was dann noch viel
viel wichtiger ist der fremdschutz also
das Weitergeben das Virus das wird durch
diesen Booster auch noch mal deutlich
verstärkt und das ist ja auch die
Hoffnung dass wenn wir möglichst viele
Leute jetzt Boostern dass wir damit auch
die Schnittstelle sehr gut eindämmen
können und von daher gibt es natürlich
die Empfehlung auch für die Jüngeren
auch wenn jetzt die Antikörper so um die
1000 sind wenn die zweite Impfung sechs
Monate her ist doch sich zu überlegen ob
man sich Boostern lassen kann wobei für
den Selbstschuss natürlich so die
Notwendigkeit nicht unbedingt da ist
aber sicherlich für diesen fremdschutz
deshalb Prof Carsten Watzl vielen
herzlichen Dank für die medizinische
Einschätzung unseres großen
Antikörpertest die wir gestern hier im
fur jedes Axel springer-hauses
durchgeführt haben 50 Kollegen haben wir
eingeladen 150 sind gekommen du warst
auch mit dabei Martha weiß aus unserer
Redaktion Leben und Wissen vielen Dank
auch für deinen Besuch im stud